foreign
[Applause]
Adele pausing her Vegas residency to
give a birthday shout out to a special
someone
taking a moment in the middle of her
weekends with Adele Set to wish
boyfriend Rich Paul a happy birthday
[Applause]
followed by a rendition of the
celebratory song
happy birthday
to you
happy birthday
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the serenade honors Rich's 41st year
around the Sun
the couple have been dating since 2021
first sparking romance rumors last
summer while courtside at an NBA game
fast forward two months later they made
things Instagram official
foreign
a year later Adele gave fans insight
into her relationship with Rich telling
Elle quote I've never been in love like
this I'm obsessed with him I'm at the
time in my life and the older I get the
more and more I love myself and I'm
enjoying my life
she also opened up about her hopes of
expanding her family adding quote I
definitely want more kids I'm a
homemaker and I'm a matriarch and a
stable life helps me with my music but
right now all I got in my brain is Vegas
[Music]
after postponing her residency at
Caesar's Palace earlier this year I'm so
sorry but um
my show ain't ready last month she
kicked things off with a bang the
Superstar brought it all to the stage
with this illusion of her piano
seemingly melting away during none other
than Set Fire to the Rain
[Music]
and this disappearing act leaving the
crowd stunned
[Music]
and it seems Adele's keeping up with
Tick-Tock Trends she channeled her best
Megan the stallion with this one
because
[Music]
now check out this moment Adele's
hilarious fan encounter during the show
[Music]
well one thing we know for sure Adele
knows just how to get the crowd moving
and singing along even if just for a
birthday shout out
hey beautiful
[Applause]
[Music]